[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace dos años llegábamos por primera vez
a la comunidad del castillo en galiana
después de todo un proceso de
aprendizaje de crecimiento de caernos de
crecer y entender en qué consiste el
empoderamiento y el desarrollo social
llegábamos a esta comunidad y sentías el
aire limpio el olor a knicks está mal a
las tortillas recién hechas y estás a
los animales y sus respectivos olores
también
y convocamos a toda la comunidad para
tener una primera reunión y en esta
primera reunión fueron relativamente
bastantes personas a lo que acostumbraba
mente sucede
y cuando llegamos allí estábamos
acomodando todo recibiendo la gente
poniendo las sillas
voy al frente me empiezo como al
rotafolio con el que íbamos a trabajar y
de pronto llegué a una señora
acercándose al frente y sergio conmigo y
me dice
guapo y dígame qué le sirvo que le doy
este me dice no voy a ponerme aquí
porque no veo atrás no total privada
señora no se preocupen de seis meses
joven no sé leer ni escribir pero quiero
ayudar
esto me cambió totalmente la manera de
percibir ese día y le dije señora no se
preocupe porque juntos nos vamos a
ocupar en encontrar la solución dentro
de nuestras capacidades al problema que
tengamos y lo que podamos hacer lo vamos
hacer juntos ese día nos dedicamos a
conocer a la comunidad
junto con ellos a resolver que talentos
teníamos que áreas de oportunidad
teníamos también que resolver
cuáles eran las cosas que nos
caracterizaron y nos hacían únicos como
comunidad eligieron ellos mismos a sus
líderes y con todo un proceso que siguió
después de aquello empezamos a planear
toda una serie de programas para
empoderar a esta comunidad en temas de
educación salud y proyectos productivos
que a la fecha seguimos trabajando en
ella en la comunidad del castillo sin
embargo que hubiera pasado
si hubiéramos llegado a esta comunidad
con toda una perspectiva diferente y en
este proceso hubiéramos pues tal vez
regalado cosas o llevado solamente
comida o llegado en diciembre a regalar
vestiduras y que pasa ha sido en la
catalina no me hubiera dicho esto en un
principio qué pasa si si no hubiera
escuchado a esta persona si no hubiera
escuchado él yo quiero hacer el cambio y
que viniera de la misma comunidad
probablemente una cosa totalmente
diferente y qué es lo que sucede
cuando llegamos nosotros a una situación
y queremos hacer el bien pasa algo
comúnmente y es que se nos viene a la
cabeza esta frase no hace el bien sin
mirar a quién
y realmente
lo que creo que tenemos que hacer es
primero analizar la frase que estamos
diciendo aquí yo creo que primeramente
extraigamos la segunda parte digamos el
sin mirar a quién a qué nos estamos
refiriendo y creo que estamos de acuerdo
que lo que tratamos de decir aquí es que
no estamos distinguiendo no estamos
discriminando y estamos tratando de
incluir a cualquier persona sin importar
su raza su sexo su el lugar de donde
venga su edad etcétera entonces si si
tomamos este concepto de sin mirar a
quién y lo incluimos en hacer bien en
hacer el bien digamos que por lo pronto
vamos a quitar esta parte de la fórmula
y quedémonos con hacer el bien y hacer
el bien tiene que ser sin hacer
distinciones cuando todos somos iguales
sin embargo creo que más bien hay que
preguntarnos
el bien para quien y es que muchas veces
se siente bien bonito cuando tenemos
algo y vamos a regalarlo a alguien y
cuando tenemos tal vez una empresa que
produce muchísimo arroz y tal vez en
haití cuando hay un terremoto pues vamos
y regalamos este arroz sin pensar que
probablemente estamos derrumbando la
economía local y cambiando toda la
manera de ser de un ecosistema o tal vez
cuando tenemos por ejemplo esta ropa que
compramos sin pensar simplemente porque
tenemos dinero y en diciembre le
regalamos a esa gente que no tiene o que
es menos que nosotros es pobre como
definimos la riqueza
creo que tenemos que hacernos esta
pregunta y realmente a partir de ello
podemos pensar que es hacer el bien y a
quién le estamos haciendo ese bien y si
se siente muy bonito se siente increíble
realmente en un principio el bien no lo
estamos haciendo a nosotros mismos
y solemos que haya en este modelo el que
tiene que es el que domina el que tiene
el poder que tiene el dinero le da a
aquel que no tiene el miserable no
y esto tiene que cambiar tiene que
cambiar esto el día de hoy si es que
queremos cambiar el mundo y como decía
confucio si queremos cambiar el mundo
empieza por tu nación y es que esto me
cambia tu nación empieza por tu ciudad y
empieza por tu familia y empieza por ti
mismo entonces
esto en tus palabras se le llama
asistencialismo y pues irónicamente el
existencialismo bajo este modelo que
decimos sin mirar a quien sin hacer
diferencias y cuando todos somos iguales
sorpresa a lo que estamos llegando es a
un tema totalmente irónico a la
desigualdad de hecho según la oxfam y el
coneval esta metodología del
asistencialismo a lo que más nos lleva
es a un con un concepto totalmente
contrario si en un principio decíamos
que el mirar sin mirar a quién
significaba cómo distinguir lo que
estamos haciendo es incrementar la
desigualdad y en méxico esto es una
crisis y no nomás en méxico en todo el
mundo en el mundo el 27 por ciento de la
riqueza se concentra en 1% de la
población es ridículo y en méxico
también sucede una situación muy similar
aquí está el hombre más rico de
latinoamérica y él junto con otras nueve
personas ocho hombres dos mujeres
comparten la riqueza de aproximadamente
el 50 por ciento de la población en
pobreza del país
desigualdad el existencialismo no está
resolviendo la situación de pobreza y no
nos está llevando a construir un mejor
lugar el contrario está provocando más
desigualdad
al final de cuentas las empresas que es
lo que buscan utilidad que lo que
buscamos ganar más dinero y según
fridman lo que estamos buscando
beneficiar es a un pequeño grupo de
personas llamados accionistas que son
los tomadores de decisiones y son
aquellos que están invirtiendo el dinero
y al final de cuentas la utilidad se
mide en pesos o en la respectiva moneda
debemos hacernos la pregunta sabemos
realmente lo que estamos haciendo cuando
queremos hacer el bien sabemos en qué
consisten estas acciones nos hemos
puesto a pensar si para cambiar el mundo
realmente sabemos que necesita ese mundo
que necesita nuestra nación que necesita
nuestra ciudad nuestra familia nuestra
persona nos hemos puesto a pensar eso
nos hemos preguntado
y a partir de ello regresa al punto
inicial que un hito se siente
podríamos decir que hacer el bien a cómo
lo percibimos hoy en día se parece al
arte el arte es estético se ve bonito
inclusive me hace ver bien si estoy
ayudando a los demás a mi empresa le
hace ver bien sido no esto sido no
aquello y lo me voy bueno ya puse mi
granito de arena
pero qué pasa
el beneficiado somos nosotros cuando
realmente hay otra parte que tenemos que
considerar y la principal diferencia
entre el arte y el diseño es que el
diseño además de que se ve bonito
funciona también y para esto creo que
tenemos que cambiar totalmente esa
mentalidad de hacer el bien sin mirar a
quién y empezar nos a meter a la cabeza
y en ello a nuestras acciones hace el
bien mirando a quién y para esto lo
hacen los diseñadores utilizamos una
metodología muy práctica que algunos de
ustedes ya habrán escuchado que se llama
el design thinking el design thinking es
una metodología basada en el pensamiento
en el diseño y comienza con empatizar un
paso muy importante para que en base a
ello entendamos el problema desde la
raíz entendamos cuál es la situación
real por la cual estamos pasando por la
cual está pasando nuestra familia
nuestra sociedad nuestra nación nuestro
mundo y a partir de ello entendiendo
realmente el problema creemos una
solución
realmente lo resuelva empecemos a
definir qué es lo que está sucediendo
empecemos a idear cómo lo podemos
solucionar hagamos un prototipo lo
saquemos al mercado y en ello podamos
estar integrando constantemente y si no
funciona regresamos porque no funciona y
no deja ahí arrumbadas a esas personas
que queremos inclusive ayudar
debemos alejarnos de este modelo
existencial y comenzar a pensar con el
diseño con empatizar con realmente
entender qué es lo que está pasando y en
base a ello crear soluciones
la empatía es algo que tenemos que hacer
todos los días
y en fratello después de ese proceso que
les comentaba en un inicio que pasamos
lo empezamos a implementar y empezamos a
entender cómo a esta comunidad del
castillo
habían ciertos ladrillos que los hacían
fuertes en sus personas pero también
había áreas de oportunidades y unos a
otros se podían complementar se pueden
unir y podían crear mayor fuerza para
llegar un bien común un bien que iba
mucho más allá del bien personal un bien
en donde cada uno de nosotros pone lo
que tenemos y logra algo mucho más
grande de lo que queremos lograr para
nosotros mismos después de todo un
proceso de integración y de dos años de
trabajo hemos estado creando una
metodología replicable para otras
comunidades que a ningún tiempo es
personalizable porque parte del nuevo
principio empatizar y entender cuál es
la situación que cada una de esas
comunidades está viviendo a final de
cuentas
lo que decía fridman de estas empresas
que miden su ganancia en utilidades
económicas y solamente por los
accionistas le contrapone otra teoría
una persona de un apellido muy similar
que es free man y freeman por el otro
lado ahora que no solamente tenemos que
enfocarnos en nosotros mismos y esto
aplica para todos para todos los que
están aquí escuchando para los que están
viendo esto
no solamente somos nosotros que tenemos
que salir beneficiados no solamente
nosotros somos los que tenemos que salir
beneficiados porque esto tiene que ser
sostenible y en nuestra pasión podemos
encontrar también el ayudar a los demás
tenemos que pensar más allá de nosotros
e involucrar a los stakeholders oa los
grupos de interés o lass a los
interesados en estas partes
quiénes son ellos nuestros colaboradores
nuestra familia sus familias el mercado
los proveedores etcétera si no pensamos
con esta mentalidad nuestros proyectos
nuestras acciones no son sostenibles
tenemos que empatizar y entender qué es
lo que está pasando y en base a ello
otra vez proponer soluciones
al final de cuentas
el asistencialismo no funciona para
resolver los problemas del mundo tenemos
que empezar a crear empresas sociales
emprendimientos sociales que al mismo
tiempo pueden ayudar a la sociedad y al
mismo tiempo pueden ser negocio una cosa
no está pelea con la otra
tiene que ser sostenible todo lo que
hagamos y esta manera sea nuestro mundo
también sostenible
nos queremos ver bien en este proceso de
hacer el bien nos queremos vernos guapos
pero realmente que sea como dijo doña
catalina un guau ponerme a trabajar para
que las cosas sucedan para que las cosas
sucedan en conjunto con las personas que
estamos trabajando porque si no volvemos
al mismo punto estaremos haciendo el
bien sin mirar a quien pensando nosotros
mismos y buscando beneficiarnos más allá
de lo que podamos impactar las otras
personas consciente o inconscientemente
es positiva o negativamente el mundo
necesita humanos todos todos los que
estamos aquí tenemos un talento tenemos
algo que nos hace únicos
también tenemos áreas de oportunidad
todos tenemos la posibilidad de crear un
impacto positivo
y lo sabemos que lo mejor de todo pero
está nosotros tomar acción para que esto
lleve a un mejor lugar el mundo necesita
más humanos el mundo necesita gente viva
necesita gente que tenga los ojos
abiertos que tenga la mente abierta que
tenga los oídos abiertos que esté
dispuesta a crear empatía
y en ello
hacer el bien mirando a quién
enamorarse del problema
y no de la solución para que cuando
creemos soluciones
juntos por un mundo mejor no estemos
creando más problemas gracias
[Música]